Lee.
I'm just not sold.
Did you?
Oh No.
And then Konya had some good points,
but I don't know.
Did you see that Candice Owens and Tomi Lahren?
We're getting into it on Twitter today?
No.
Like,
like two weeks ago I missed it.
It was this big cat fight.
Really?
Yeah,
it was hilarious.
What did they say?
Like Tommy's was subtweeting her,
she wouldn't use her name.
She goes,
oh,
you know,
blah blah blah blah blah.
And Candice is like,
Tommy Comma,
like you're jealous cause your careers that disaster,
blah blah,
blah,
blah.
Yeah,
it was,
it was before I'd be on the scenario.
Yeah,
it's extensively Kanya turned on.
Candace throw her under the bus.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
Kanye turned on Candace.
Oh yeah.
He says I'm not involved and I'm not involved in politics anymore.
How's that turning on Candace?
Cause she could use her name in the tweets.
What'd he say?
He said,
Candace,
whatever.
I find the tweet if you want.
But,
so she was,
I don't want to speak for her,
but she launched this whole Brexit thing and basically implied that he was
involved and he's like,
I'm not,
I've been used by people in politics and not doing it.
Well,
look,
she,
she went at it hard.
Oh yeah.
They both turn on Kanye now the ship was doomed to sync from the start,
but hunger for fame and money was placed over the movement.
Funny how he was a free thinker in quotes before and now he's a trader and
quotes sounds a lot like a tactic of the left.
I like how she capitalize.
It'll all in left.
Yeah.
You made your bed now lie in it.
I think she means,
I think he'd be laying there.
Yeah.
Well maybe not.
Maybe it's a double entendre.
Maybe.
Maybe it'd be in factual or all the Tommy.
I think I can Expedia speak on behalf of people on both sides of the political
aisle and say,
we are sorry about your failed career.
That this is hilarious.
And she's saying this,
she's literally had a career in this for about eight months and you're failed
career,
you know,
she used to run an anti Trump website.
A doxing set,
you mean?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
The desperation to be relevant again by constantly serving me and,
or attacking Kathy Griffin weekly.
Make sure to tag Kazen bode well for any movement.
Grow Up.
Whenever anyone writes grow up.
I always hear it in Karpman's voice.
Is that it?
Did they go out into the further or is it just one little bit of back and forth?
Yeah,
that's sort of silly.
it is.
Oh,
wins.
Went on the defensive Wednesday after West rejected claims that he designed or
created blacks at t shirts.
What does black set black black lights it.
They could shut it.
Called a black set.
Yeah.
Like they mean the black still leaving the Democratic Party.
Why didn't they do that?
You'd have to ask Candace and our Kanye and her.
Kathy Griffin.
Yeah.
Well I get they did it because of Brexit.
You have a black sits Exeter.
Yeah.
Blit yeah.
Eh,
it's not bad black exit.
Yeah,
but black state is also black exit.
Yeah.
It's called blaxploitation the movies.
Right,
but exit is spelled e.
X.
I.
T.
He just have be l and then e.
X.
I.
T.
It's actually better
if you want to be sure.
Precisely spelling is better,
but in terms of how,
how it's said,
I think blacks,
it sounds,
lacks it.
I'd look to
exit.
I don't think either.
You don't have to abbreviate exit.
You just keep exit in there and just be out at the beginning of it and it works
or it collects.
It also works.
Let's,
I've sure Candace think you're married to your idea of blacks.
It's needed to let it go.
You're a writer.
You know how to kill your babies.
I don't have any black vegans.
No excavating writing.
You've got your darlings.
Kill your darling till your shitty ideas.
Yeah.
Blacks.
It's like shitty idea blacks.
It is where it's at.
Is it?
Yeah.
Brexit.
They were right.
Do you think that there's gonna be a lot of people,
black people leading the Democratic Party?
I don't think so.
Yeah.
No,
I think there's going to be a few that recognize that it's a genuine pathway to
attention.
And I think there's going to be,
a lot of people are going to sit home.
That's where African American a,
listen,
there is few on both sides of the aisle that are contrarians.
Hucksters you know,
there's,
there's two different types of people.
The contrarians are people that don't like the fact that they are being told
that as an African American I have to vote Democrat and I have to lean left and
they're like,
fuck this,
you know,
you don't tell me what to do.
And then they go that way.
I think we're getting a little bit of that from Kanye West.
And then there's people that recognize that there is,
there's legitimate pathway to start them to attention to.
You know,
it's just a,
it's a career and being like reciting conservative talking points as an African
American.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's a,
it's affirmative action.
Yeah.
But it's,
um,
and especially,
you know,
if you can get a little juice on some sort of argument with some Tommy Lauren
chick or any of these,
I was confused.
Her and Lauren Southern,
they're very different.
I know,
but they're both hot.
They're both hot plates on.
That's all I say.
I'm not really paying attention to what they're saying.
Well,
I don't think that's fair to Lauren.
How dare you?
What do you mean?
How'd there has,
is Lauren the superior to the title?
I'm not going to s I mean,
if I wouldn't say it,
not fair to Lauren.
So you mean Lauren is better than Tommy?
Uh,
I think Lauren,
Tommy is very much someone who's there to have a,
uh,
standard Republican point of view,
which she does well.
And write your present.
Lauren is more of kind of a filmmaker and she's much edgier.
I mean,
she's,
uh,
she went with Molyneux to Australia.
There was all this beef.
Um,
I'll go in Australia like they want it to stop their talks.
Uh,
she's done.
She's going to South Africa to do work.
They want to stop everybody's talks,
who want stop.
Tommy's talks to,
they want to start [inaudible] Lawrence.
Much more controversial.
Real Watch.
More controversial.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
She's very anti anti immigrant.
She went to Europe to see the migrant camps.
Um,
so you're not going to see Lauren really on these like mainstream outlets.
Um.